d- d- 2.5 3 amps target is 2.5 5 amps
the current is increasing 2.5 8 amps the
panels are generating electricity and
everyone is pleased this solar energy
park in southern Germany can supply more
than 30 megawatts of electricity the
panels were made in China maintenance
engineers say the quality is good and
that a system as large as this is only
worth it if the panel's come from China
but what about after sales service MMD
aki-nee's and Chinese manufacturers are
starting to set up service branches and
have some in Germany but they're still
catching up mr. calhoune the EU
manufacturers Lobby Pro Sun says service
isn't the problem
China sells the panels for half of what
it costs to make them in the law of
international trade that's known as
dumping Germany invests billions in the
latest technologies to remain
internationally competitive but experts
say it's still not enough to outpace
Chinese government subsidies I'm Mac the
truck isn't the company subject to
market conditions would go broke
immediately but in China government
subsidies are used to make up the
difference she costs China a lot of
money but they use government banks they
land companies lots of money but in the
end manufacturers don't pay it back so
sure I would acquit include then the
money is just gone and it's ask a team
dick
this German wholesaler has no trouble
with Chinese domestic business practices
he's been doing this for three decades
he used to sell German products but for
about five years now he's been filling
his warehouses with Chinese goods
he says the Chinese subsidies only hurt
manufacturers everyone else in Germany
profits he strongly opposed to punitive
tariffs Buford GB Germany supplies China
with silicon it supplies the machines to
make the solar cells and the wafers and
the modules safer here still it would be
wrong if they
stepped in all of a sudden simply
because the Chinese used German machines
and with lower labor costs can sell
their modules at much lower prices than
here to beat naziha when does this file
the abbot lets the bus with jobs in
Germany's machine-tool sector depend on
whether the manufacturers can sell to
China it's interesting for about a year
now business is dropped in nil because
China has built up so much excess
capacity but they don't need the
machines anymore you got kind of more
machinery ball in there five-year plan
it says that in the future they want to
make the machines themselves so really
what they're trying to do is copy
everything in China electrician helmet
knockin burger says China's market share
of 80 percent isn't problematic the
inexpensive products keep his business
booming if conditions stay the same he
can continue to employ 12 workers then
get soft if they impose a punitive
tariffs and they're talking about
something from 37 to 57 percent then
it's all over I can just close up the
business this farmer only wanted a small
solar energy system on his roof but he
opted for something three times the size
thanks to generous solar power subsidies
he's using inexpensive Chinese panels
I've already used these modules on
another system and they worked well very
well even so I said this is the one I
want again in the Germans had made them
in China under patents so I think what's
the problem I think it was loosen a
knock-on effect of China's dumping
policies can be seen in Germany's
countryside some say imposing punitive
tariffs could change that look
you